a crowning moment for europe's largest
infrastructure project
queen elizabeth lending her name to
london's biggest single transport
upgrade for more than a century
a decade in the making the line is a
journey into the future forget the
cramped tunnels of the city's 19th
century tube network this is something
else
light filled chambers serenely curved
concrete and glass it feels like a huge
modern art gallery not a mode of
transport it provides state-of-the-art
fast clean ambient services that
londoners will flock to so that plus the
economic benefit something like 42
billion pound injection to the uk
economy this truly is a game changer for
london
the trains are smoother and faster than
anything seen in the city before
speeding travellers from one side of
central london to the other in nine
minutes as the uk races to reach its
target of net zero carbon emissions by
2050 public transport is key
these are cathedral-like otherworldly
spaces designed to accommodate this
growing metropolis making the morning
commute less of a squeeze
and more of a breeze
but at 23 billion dollars it hasn't come
cheap that's 5 billion more than
expected twice the price of the london
2012 olympics or 15 buckingham palaces
the drop in passenger numbers during the
pandemics left a 1.8 billion dollar hole
in transport for london's finances and
with 20 percent fewer people using the
underground network choosing to work
from home instead
there are concerns about when this new
line will start paying for itself
the process of boring tunnels and
pouring concrete was finished years ago
returning this into the most advanced
digital railway in the world was a 120
kilometer long it nightmare this is a
probably the world's most complex fully
digital railway it undoubtedly has the
world's most complicated signaling
system with four different signaling
systems we've got 16 million digital
parts on this railway so to bring them
all together has been quite a challenge
actually but we've we kind of got there
in the end and i think customers will
reap the benefits of that
this entire project is one massive
exercise in engineering problem solving
instead of an escalator here a funicular
railway
on may the 24th when the line opens to
the public these 250 meter long
platforms will reverberate with the
sound of thousands of travelers
queen elizabeth was born in an age of
steam trains now the elizabeth line is
driving the future of digital transport
neve barca al jazeera london